foreign
[Music]
for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello
we come in peace
come on Drax seriously dude
foreign
[Applause]
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one last time
into the forever
a beautiful
girl
[Music]
and we'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
he'll know people kill one guy one
stupid guy who no one loves now you're
just making it sad
they made only a small appearance in
Thor love and thunder and could be seen
briefly in I am Groot but next year it's
finally time for them to return the
probably most chaotic superheroes of the
universe will finally have their last
big movie appearance we're talking about
the Guardians of the Galaxy of course
they have already appeared in five MCU
films followed by the holiday special at
the end of November before we will get
to see them in the grand finale in May
2023 but what will the plot be like and
what is the status on set now that so
many of the group have left the MCU
these are the questions we deal with in
this video of course we will also go
into the freshly released trailer as it
has told us a lot about what will happen
in the movie
obviously one of the most important
questions is when will the movie be set
it is clear that it will take place
after end game but years have gone by
since the final battle against Thanos as
we've seen in many series and movies a
lot has also happened since then as you
surely know after the fight against
Thanos the Guardians joined forces with
Thor to form the asgardians of the
Galaxy we were able to see a part of the
story at the beginning of Thor love and
thunder however we also saw that they
parted ways again if we take a look at
the current cast of the film we can see
that one name in particular isn't
mentioned namely that of Chris Hemsworth
so it can be assumed that the God of
Thunder will not be fighting alongside
Star-Lord and the others this time
around we conclude the two movies play
parallel to each other or that the plot
of Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 takes
place after Thor 4. this is of course
only an assumption on the part of Disney
there is still no more detailed
information
the cast is actually pretty much
complete and since Comic-Con in San
Diego we know about most of the new cast
Editions
for the time being not much will change
among the Guardians Chris Pratt will
return to his role as Star-Lord and Dave
Bautista set to play Drax for One Last
Time Karen Gillen Palm clementieff Vin
Diesel and Bradley Cooper are also back
as nebular mantis Groot and Rocket
however the Guardians seem to have two
new cast members first we can already
spot Cosmo the space dog for the first
time in the trailer for the holiday
special the golden retriever Labrador
mix is probably the most famous dog in
the comics and his voice is provided by
Maria bakaloa in addition it is not yet
clear whether craglin amponteri will
continue to fight with the ravagers or
join Peter and the others after all
craglin is played by Sean Gunn the
younger brother of director James Gunn
who is no longer part of the Guardians
is Gamora played by Zoe Saldana she has
found a new group with which she can
cross the line in the universe namely
the ravagers at the end of the last part
they still offered yondu udanta a
dignified farewell after his heroic
death who is going to lead the ravagers
now is still unknown but it is certain
that Sylvester Stallone has stuck her
ogord known in the comics as Starhawk
will have his very own crew we were able
to see him in volume 2 as well it was
him after all who granted yondu
Absolution upon his death to be buried
with all honors in space whether there
will be flashbacks of yondu is not known
so far however Michael Rooker is not to
be found in the currently confirmed cast
list how long Gamora will remain a
ravager remains to be seen in the first
trailer we were actually able to see her
alongside the Guardians again so it
seems like the old group is coming back
together after all she is also holding a
Polaroid in another scene of course we
assume that it is an old photo of her
and Peter will there be a happy ending
for the two of them after all
in the post-credits scene of the last
movie the adversary of volume 3 was also
introduced there The High Priestess
Ayesha could be seen breeding a new
evolved Sovereign named Adam this atom
is none other than Adam Warlock in the
comics he was brought to life by a group
of researchers who wanted to make the
perfect being in the upcoming film the
role of Adam will be played by Will
Poulter it is likewise confirmed that
Elizabeth Debicki will once again slip
into the role of the high priestess
Ayesha as another antagonist we learned
through Comic-Con that Herbert Edgar
Windham AKA High evolutionary will be
featured he is trying to create a higher
Evolution through genetic experiments
you probably guessed it he is also the
creator of Rocket among the first
published images of the new movie you
can also see a shot of baby rocket
moreover at the start of the trailer the
Guardians land on a planet that is very
similar to Earth where only animal-like
creatures live but which seem to have a
humanoid form comic fans among you may
be eager to learn whether this is an
allusion to the counter Earth which was
created by the high evolutionary
whether Thor will be back for Guardians
volume 3 has not yet been clarified
nevertheless it is likely he will appear
in at least a few sequences after all he
did travel the universe with the
Guardians for a while on the other hand
he is the first hero Adam Warlock meets
in the comics and also an adversary of
high evolutionary but this is of course
still pure speculation and not confirmed
by anybody yet
it was certainly not easy to get to the
start of filming for the third part of
the film series although director James
Gunn confirmed back in March 2017 that
there would be a third part The
Mastermind behind the Guardians first
had to pack his bags after an almost 10
year old tweet of his was made public in
which he made fun of sexual assault
things were over for the time being
since this cannot be reconciled with the
strict guidelines of Disney they felt
compelled to dismiss God only after more
or less the entire star Ensemble of the
Guardians had publicly stood up for the
director did they bring Gunn back to the
project in March 2019 this allowed
production to restart with a
considerable delay the year 2020 was
originally planned as the shooting start
but of course they didn't know
beforehand that everything would turn
out differently that year thus Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 had to be added to
the long list of postponements in
addition Chris Hemsworth also expressed
interest in shooting a fourth solo film
around his character of Thor this
production was then promptly given more
attention filming on the Guardians movie
finally began at the end of 2021 the
first trailer was then shown at a press
conference at the San Diego Comic-Con
this was actually only supposed to be
shown to the Press but shortly after the
first mobile phone shots of the trailer
emerged this led to displeasure among
the fans as they have been waiting for
some footage for a long time
thanks to the trailer much is already
known about the plot and so far we can
forecast three major storylines Gunn
himself stated in a podcast that the
third and last part of the Guardians
will probably be the darkest although he
will of course not skimp on humor he
also hinted that not everyone in the
group Will Survive their final battle at
this point we would like to emphasize
that not everything we predict will turn
out that way but rather it seems
realistic to us the search for Gamora
will probably turn out to be shorter
than everyone expected after all she
shows up pretty quickly in the trailer
there however she makes it clear that
she is no longer the Gamora we knew
before end game and that she is now
turning to her own interests this will
be especially upsetting to quill but
whether there was still a happy ending
for both of them remains to be seen
Gamora certainly appears to be more
focused on gaining control of the
ravagers than engaging in a love affair
with Peter furthermore as mentioned
earlier we have gotten to see baby
rocket and his story will also play a
bigger role much to the Delight of fans
so hopefully we will not only learn how
he was created by high evolutionary but
also find out a little more about his
life before Groot in the Guardians in
addition we'll meet Rocket's best friend
Lila the modified otter lady has only
appeared in the comics thus far but if
you paid attention you might have seen
her name in the first Guardians movie
there it is next to Groot when the
Guardians are admitted to the Maximum
Security Prison of the zandarians anyway
the first images of the reunion have
already brought tears to our eyes as we
could already gather from the trailer
rocket will probably want to take
revenge on his creator for all that he
did to him already in the past movies we
have heard repeated allusions to
Rocket's painful transformation and also
in the trailer we can see cybernetic
implants beneath his skin last but
certainly not least there's Adam Warlock
as mentioned earlier Adam Warlock was
created by Earth researchers in the
comics right after his Awakening he
meets Thor and is fought by him after he
attempts to mate with Lady Sif however
Adam Warlock is not necessarily evil but
similar to Vision a being who has yet to
find his place in the universe this
Mission which he lacked at the beginning
of the comics could easily be given to
him in the movie eventually which is to
take revenge on the Guardians of the
Galaxy yeah he may end up taking a
completely different path indeed in the
comics he eventually joins the Guardians
to protect the universe and rebuild it
after a terrible disaster what is clear
here is that in the movie series it
wasn't researchers on Earth who created
Adam Warlock but the Sovereign we
finally got to watch this in the
post-credits scene of Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2. they could have been
helped by Edgar Windham AKA High
evolutionary which would make a good
connection between the Guardians and him
the fact that warlock will join the
Guardians at the end of the movie is not
that unrealistic it is clear that they
will have to regroup and as Gunn said
not everyone necessarily has to survive
of course that begs the question who
might die
the most likely scenario for us is the
death of Drex the actress fallen out
with Disney and has long announced that
this will be his final Marvel film well
that makes it very easy to Simply let
the character die besides Drex has
accomplished his great goals and Avenged
his family after the death of Ronan and
Thanos also in the trailer we saw the
Guardians in a prison again and Drex was
dragged Away by Gamora and mantis with a
gunshot wounded to the chest however
further deaths cannot be excluded for
instance Peter could sacrifice himself
for Gamora if she were to be in danger
again also the possibility of Rocket
dying cannot be ruled out indeed James
Gunn stated that he put all of himself
into the role of rocket and thus with
his departure from the franchise his
character could die as well in the lore
Rock and Lila wanted to escape from the
high evolutionary together but
unfortunately Lila didn't make it maybe
rocket will sacrifice himself this time
so that his best friend can live in
Freedom no matter who or whether someone
even dies we will surely have tears
running down our faces with the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy
that was our preview of Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. how do you imagine the
story will play out let us know in the
comments and if you like the video don't
forget to give it a thumbs up see you
next time
[Music]